of course ironically be yourself I just
got a text message from a woman who is
wanting to be a Justin Bieber look like
what do you think I'm Bella phalluses
and I'm known as the look-alike lady
I've worked as Madonna's double for 28
years and now I help guide people to
begin careers as look-alikes you do
that's definitely definitely a call I've
been getting my phone rings every single
day from people saying hey I look just
like somebody and I try to explain to
them it's not enough to just look like
somebody Rock is definitely a good
sellable act can you sound like him it's
about bringing something to the
character that you do that's that's good
I think we can we can work on it and
practice with your vocal tones to bring
it down a little bit couple octaves
lower to me it's helping other
performers get a break that they may not
get in Hollywood pressure pressing down
on me pressing down on you know man ask
for and you have to be careful what you
ask for because when I was a child I
said that I was going to travel the
world and be treated like a rock star
and I traveled all over Europe and was
treated like Freddy people are often
asking me are you always on it's a
little hard to answer because I sort of
in and yet I'm sort of not the
personalities sort of homogenized emerge
even when I look in the mirror sometimes
I'm wondering who am i today
am i Jack Who am I Norman let's figure
this out if you see me come over say
hello I'd be happy to talk to you I'm
there to welcome everybody and I just
want people to know that I'm a hugger I
think people's perceptions of
look-alikes can be questionable maybe
negative sometimes what I do is real
different I'm in a different world I
look like world but most of the people
that work in this industry are hardcore
trained actors singers dancers models
these people that go to the movies and
and hear these this music they miss it
and they want so desperately to be part
of it and what we provide is the total
immersion in a fantasy there are times
when people want me to be Jack I mean
they want me to be Jack I have been at
gigs where people will literally come up
and they will start telling me about
their brother their sister their mother
their wife they think that I'm going to
be able to provide them with the
resolution to whatever problem they're
having and all I can do is share my own
feelings what's my gut feeling in my
years as Madonna I had people crying
I've had people write me letters that
were sick and wanted to visit for
Madonna I have lived all over the world
and I've met some wonderful people many
wonderful fans many of them ache so
deeply to know Freddie because the music
has touched their lives on a deeply
personal level and when someone sees me
as Freddie Freddie is no longer dead but
alive and with you as alive as music is
you think like being in a movie or
traveling around the world would be the
most important thing but really at the
end of the day it's how you've affected
somebody that really makes a difference
of why you would want to keep doing this
I was in a crowd of 8,000 people and
there was a little old lady standing off
to the side and she was crying and when
I asked the person who was in charge I
said what's wrong is there anything I
can do to help and the person said to me
she has always in her life wanted to
meet Oprah and she figures that you're
the closest she's ever going to get to
her I went over to the lady I took a
picture with her and I hugged her
the look on her face the tears that came
rolling down her face will forever be in
my heart
and that's why I continue to do what I
do as a young girl I always wanted to
dance and sing and act
but lookalike brought me things that I
could not have imagined I could have not
dreamt up that I'd be traveling across
the world or on a giant billboard or
working with Madonna herself these are
things that I couldn't have dreamt up
and so look oh I just kind of kept
magically unfolding for me like the
opportunities and the people that I met
that's what makes it worth it
the excitement the people what we do is
special we come into your homes and into
your lives and we bring you celebrity
and sparkle and everything that you have
desired in Hollywood a lot of people
will ask me that they'll come up and ask
me oh yeah you must be making a lot of
money off of this no that's not what
it's about
what it's about is the interaction that
you have with another human being every
single day of your life if you have that
opportunity in your life to make one
person smile every single day would you
not do so the work as an impersonator is
something you can't predict and it's
amazing and magical and I say hop on the
bus with me and we will take you to
Hollywood
[Music]
you get a car you get a car you get a
car everybody gets a car